so people ask me all the time about
theories that don't make the cut well
here's one for you when i first wanted
to do an episode on falcon in the winter
soldier i was hoping that i could expose
bucky as a secret millionaire you see
falcon in the winter soldier deals a lot
with sam's financial troubles i know
your family has banked with us for
generations
but we cannot approve him which in and
of itself is kind of ridiculous
considering he's a main hired gun for
the world's most powerful private
military it's probably a theory for
another day but no one ever talks about
buck even though he's had decades to
grow his wealth while he sat in the
ground frozen i mean my schools didn't
teach me much about money but they did
teach me the power of compound interest
baby invest a bit now and in like a
bunch of years you're gonna be a
millionaire so i was like i'm gonna
calculate how much bucky barnes would
earn in interest since
1942 and i bet that we're gonna find out
that he's like one of the richest
characters in the marvel universe so i
broke out the old number cruncher thanks
to the 1942 pay readjustment act we know
how much bucky would be making
throughout his career as an army private
first class in world war ii his salary
would have been about 50 dollars a month
doesn't sound like a lot but remember
this is old-timey dollars those are
always worth a bunch more he probably
got promoted up to corporal right out of
training camp and started making 66
dollars a month by the time he visited
steve rogers at the beginning of captain
america he was a sergeant and would be
making 78 dollars a month until his last
two months in service in which a 5 bonus
would kick in earning him 81.90 that
totals just around 2 788 throughout his
military career let's then say that he
was a financially savvy guy and got
himself a 3 interest savings account
compounded monthly into which he
deposited his whole paycheck that means
that through his military career bucky
barnes would have earned roughly 4
940 and 94 cents it's not exactly what i
was hoping for and definitely not enough
money to warrant getting thrown off a
train and losing your arm but wait for
it after 78 years of compound interest
drumroll please
wait that's it it still only comes out
to 51 143 and 50 cents after 78 years
bucky is still not even beating the
average income for an american male in
2020 at 52 000 four dollars moral of the
story don't trust mr cole my 10th grade
economics teacher compound interest meh
all in on dogecoin
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that tries to do better
speaking of being better if you want to
be better at working from home check out
the interview we just did over on the
rocket learn youtube channel our sponsor
for today's episode steph and i went on
their new series big change to share our
experiences trying to work at home with
your significant other for nearly a
decade nowadays i think most of us are
going through something like that so
learn the importance of headphones desks
and honest conversations with your
roommates by checking out that episode
link is down in the description below
and at the end of the video now if you
ended up passing on the first season of
falcon in the winter soldier first of
all you missed out on a piece of the mcu
that could most definitely do better the
whole thing kind of feels rushed and
chopped to pieces it's fine i guess but
it feels like the first real marvel
property to struggle with the balance
between telling a compelling story while
also being beholden to setting up the
next five years worth of marvel plots
and merch bait that said while it
certainly wasn't one of the most highly
rated mcu projects it does present lots
of interesting ideas even if it doesn't
always do a good job of fleshing them
out case in point the iconic line to
come out of the season one finale
episode be better and what the heck that
actually means other than it just being
great meme bait quick flashback to what
leads up to this famous line in case
you've been sleeping on the series or
the last three mcu movies back in 2017
thanos that's the purple guy here
snapped half of the universe out of
existence hoof five years later the
avengers specifically hulk undid the
snap bringing everyone right back to
where they were when they disappeared
they didn't reverse time or anything
they just created some three and a half
billion people out of thin air now back
when i told the world that thanos
unfortunately was right i talked about
how a new abundance of resources and
production would make life for the
remaining population significantly
easier well this time around we actually
have the opposite situation a world that
had dealt with and moved past the three
and a half billion deaths built to only
serve some three and a half billion
people suddenly having to serve double
that amount that's the primary cause of
the events of falcon and the winter
soldier our sort of antagonist carly
morgenthau has benefited tremendously
from what's now referred to as the blip
along with a bunch of other outcasts
refugees and marginalized groups who
fled their oppressive countries during
the snap times these people do not want
to go back to how life was before the
blip and their organization the flag
smashers has the goal of keeping country
borders down to allow displaced people
to stay in their new lives but carly
isn't exactly peaceful about it in her
final act she attacks a meeting of the
global repatriation council which is an
organization aiming to return things to
the way they were pre-snap she's
eventually stopped by sam wilson as the
brand new captain america and killed by
the power broker cut and roll credits
right wrong sam as an ethnic minority
sympathizes with their mission and
lectures the global repatriation council
members about being better in a nearly
four minute monologue for four minutes
he speaks truth to power yeah stick it
to those government bigwigs is what the
swelling and passion music wants you to
believe but when you actually listen to
sam's words they sound pretty but
they're ultimately hollow our
peacekeeping troops will begin
relocating people soon the terrorists
only set us back a bit you have to stop
calling them terrorists stop calling
them terrorists he says about a group of
people that bombed buildings and killed
people to get their message across no
matter how noble your message is that's
just not okay but it continues and the
people who reappeared only to find
someone else living in their family home
they just end up homeless look i get it
but you have no idea how complicated
this situation is you know what you're
right and that's a good thing we finally
have a common struggle now way to
deflect the question there sam
government dude's like hey you don't get
it superhero guy this is a tough problem
to solve and sam responds with a well
yeah but now you know what it's like to
feel helpless and hated by people that
is that is not the point of this
conversation sam the senators are
talking about how there's no perfect
solutions to these humanitarian problems
you're talking about why it's time they
get hate for their decisions you see all
these are two separate conversations
that have nothing to do with each other
by the end of the speech here's his
advice you've got to do better senator
you've got to step up be better be
better at what solving the complicated
housing food and humanitarian issues of
a planet that just doubled in population
just feed everyone find everyone at home
give everyone medical care clean water a
job and while we're at it that better
probably include fair working conditions
and appropriate retirement child care
access to technology literally
everything a functioning society needs
just provide all of that easy but you
have no idea how complicated this
situation is we finally have a common
struggle now no no you don't your job is
punching aliens in the face just do
better now before i ruin this idea for
everyone which is of course where this
is going because this is film theory i
want to acknowledge that for as hard of
a time as i'm giving sam here and more
importantly not sam himself but the
writers of this scene his message does
resonate with a lot of us at the end of
the incredibly hard year that was 2020.
in 2020 every single person watching
this and writing editing or publishing
this felt like our health our
communities our families jobs financial
security and personal liberties were all
put into jeopardy no matter how many
weird plot choices or confusing
narrative elements falcon and the winter
soldier had sam's sentiment here is
hashtag relatable every person out there
has wanted to say something like this to
a local national or international
leadership person but that said what
exactly is he saying it's one thing to
speak pretty words but it's another
thing to actually solve the problem he's
literally asking this council to solve
all humanitarian problems throughout the
entire world with the stroke of a pen
well let's see if we can put into words
what doing better would actually look
like this one's gonna be great friends
one youtube video to try and solve the
world's limited supply of resources i am
sure that this is going to be achievable
in every way first let's talk about the
global repatriation council we're told
by carly that the grc's primary interest
is the people who got blipped out of
existence for five years and not the
people who actually lived through those
five years to start this is a strange
philosophy that goes completely counter
to the legal system of almost every
first world country everyone who has
blipped away was essentially presumed
dead by everyone left behind and as such
the governments would start dealing with
their estates as if they had died while
different countries and states have a
range of laws they all tend to follow
the same general philosophy you can't
un-spill a glass of milk think about it
like this after someone dies there are
plenty of assets that just go on to the
next akin things like cars and houses
are obvious but literally all your stuff
goes to someone else and while i love my
parents if something awful should happen
to them i'm not going to be hanging on
to every pair of my dad's underwear for
the rest of my life also my parents have
a lot of the same stuff i have maybe
their lawnmower is better than mine but
that just means that when i inherit
their lawnmower mine's going into a
garage sale usually within a month of
somebody dying or being declared dead
their former possessions get strewn
across dozens of owners and their money
starts being spent as such most laws are
written such that it's not easy for
someone who's disappeared to come back
and reclaim their life one state that
does handle things better is
pennsylvania we're declaring somebody
dead without clear evidence that they
are actually dead requires the claimant
to post a bond for the value of the dead
person's assets this way if the person
does show up the state can either return
the assets or at least give them a fair
bit of money to help compensate them but
when half the population gets blipped
out in front of everyone's eyes it might
be considered clear evidence of death if
not i feel awful for the bonds industry
of mcu pennsylvania which just went
entirely bankrupt to pay for half the
state's reappearance speaking of
inheritance i think there's some logic
that we can all follow about how it's
not really fair to give someone back a
house after another person took care of
it for the last five years houses are
assets but they're not like a bar of
gold that just sits there gaining value
houses need constant maintenance lawns
need to be mowed gutters need to be
cleaned roofs need retiling all as a
completely natural part of owning a home
if you rent an apartment your landlord
is probably handling most of those
things which is why you pay them
probably more than you would be paying a
bank for the mortgage on the same
property that means that if you aren't
actively maintaining a house or actively
paying rent on the house someone else is
laboring for you for free you might be
surprised to know that most countries
have thought of this and actually have
developed laws around what's called
squatters rights squatters rights very
significantly from country to country
and state to state like any set of rules
but the general concept is that you
can't kick someone out of their place of
residence without warning even if they
aren't paying for it now the grc is
clearly giving a lot of people in the
world warning that they're about to be
evicted from their homes but also most
of these people are presumably paying
for those homes in spider-man far from
home ant-may tells us that she appeared
suddenly in her old apartment where
people were living when i've lived back
to my apartment the family that was
living there was very confused the wife
thought that i was a mistress it doesn't
sound like that family was just
squatting there it sounds like they had
legitimately moved in even if not many
states have statutes that allow a
squatter someone who's been living there
for free to pay to gain ownership of the
home if they can prove that they've
maintained or improved the property
since most of these residents had
actually been paying the whole time the
law as it's written would ensure that
they had the rights to stay there so
yeah sam has a point here the global
repatriation council is doing some
really weird business in that they're
trying to corral people back to their
former countries when legally these
people should have the right to live in
the properties where they're currently
living that being said this is totally
an unprecedented world event clearly
you're gonna have to make some drastic
choices can't just leave 3.5 billion
people homeless and the fact is that now
the demand for everything from food
housing clothing medicine all of it has
doubled in every possible way according
to everyone's high school introductory
economics course the increasing demand
with the flat line of supply should mean
that the prices on everything in the
world would be skyrocketing to
unbelievable levels alternatively if
price controls are in place there's
going to be shortages of pretty much
everything as humanity scoops up what
little supply there is and while all the
rest of this is happening the people who
have just reappeared need immediate help
i mean most are immediately homeless
most are immediately jobless their
families and most importantly their
assets are just gone to who knows where
the point is that these returners don't
have the ability to pay skyrocketing
prices to keep up with demand so the grc
has this really difficult choice here if
they create some sort of legislation to
keep prices from doubling overnight they
might save families from being evicted
and starving but they also might force
everyone into an extreme resource
shortage faster and worse than it would
happen naturally so tell me captain
america which of these options is doing
better well what if there was a third
option in a world where we've all been
watching our mailboxes and making our
memes about the covid relief checks what
about government relief open up that
money printer and give people the cash
most money today is digital and the
federal government could just fulfill
bank's money orders by literally
printing enough money to replenish the
empty accounts of those who are snapped
away this however causes yet another big
problem inflation even just with 2020
the united states federal reserve hasn't
exactly been reserved about printing a
lot of money to infuse into the parts of
the economy that needed it the most over
the last 18 months we're seeing tons of
articles about inflation actually
happening right here right now as we
speak because that's just what happens
when the market floods with a lot of new
money for us inflation might be more
temporary but in a post blip world the
amount of money that would have to be
printed to reimburse 3.5 billion people
would cause inflation at a level that is
impossible to comprehend imagine every
country in the world just printing
banknotes they immediately become
useless pieces of paper if you need a
primer on inflation we actually covered
it in depth over on game theory when we
talked about the world of warcraft
economy now when inflation gets out of
control it's called hyperinflation and
you can see modern examples of it in
places like zimbabwe zimbabwe's troubles
began in the 1990s when dictator robert
mugabe instituted a racial policy to
evict white landowners from their farms
and replace them with black farmers
instead however many of these newly
landed farmers had no farming experience
and little in the ways of capital to
finance things like equipment so in just
a few years zimbabwe's food output had
dropped nearly 45
however mugabe wanted to continue
intervening in wars in his region and
thus started printing zimbabwe dollars
to pay for his military at its peak
zimbabwe was experiencing a staggering
89.7 sextillion percent annual inflation
any money that you acquired at the
beginning of the year was completely
worthless by the end of the year to put
that kind of inflation into perspective
with numbers like that it would make
jeff bezos the world's richest man at
186 billion dollars worth a fraction of
a penny in a year now obviously things
wouldn't be that bad for most countries
printing money for the blip citizens
since the most that they would probably
do is increase inflation by a hundred
percent but that's still way more
inflation than most countries can handle
right after its founding in 1776 the
united states experienced the most
inflation in its history with its
currency inflating 29.78
it is never a good solution but it is
technically a solution now for people
like carly morgenthau in the show the
people who've survived for the last five
years this solution will definitely suck
because any money that she and everyone
else around her have earned honestly in
the past five years of working will
instantly be worth half or less than it
was before and items will suddenly cost
at least double people who were
disenfranchised or below the poverty
line have now spent the last five years
earning more than they could have ever
earned before because now their labor is
more needed than ever in a post-snap
world suddenly though with all this
inflation they're disenfranchised again
and all the money that they've earned is
worth a fraction of what it used to be
on top of all of it with this massive
population flood labor now becomes
incredibly cheap there are so many
people who need jobs so the competition
to actually keep the job that you had
during the blip is gonna be completely
impossible so at that point you have 3.5
billion people who are sort of okay 3.5
billion people are pretty mad at the
other half and very very expensive bread
for everyone so what is captain
america's plan here well he might
actually have the answers even though he
doesn't feel like sharing in the falcon
and the winter soldier we watched sam
deal with a lot of the issues the blip
are facing he can't get a loan because
he has five years of no income he's
afraid that he'll need to sell his
family's vote and his sister is worried
about the rent going up again sam
doesn't really solve any of those
problems but he does manage to get his
mother's boat fixed up by cashing in on
goodwill he rallies his community behind
a common goal and he gets it done carly
talks about the same thing when she
opines for the days when it wasn't every
man for themselves instead we got a
glimpse of how things could be no the
reality of the situation isn't be better
senator man it's inspire others to be
better at the end of the day carly was
wrong to be attacking the grc not just
because it's an international crime and
she was turning her friends into
biological weapons but because the grc
isn't the ones with the power here
they're not going to be able to come up
with a solution that's going to be
satisfying to everyone that sort of
thing is just impossible country borders
or no country borders what needs to be
better is people's willingness to work
together as individuals to get through
times of crisis the good news is that
unbeknownst to the filming team who shot
the show starting back in october of
2019 people are actually capable of that
they're capable of collectively doing
things for the greater good like wearing
masks delivering food donating money and
time and literal oxygen at least enough
of us are good enough at that that it
can get the entire world through a major
global upheaval carly was right the grc
is trying to make things the way they
were before the blip and that's a bad
plan at this point in the mcu people
need to collectively be doing things
they had never done before the grc is
trying to make things the way they were
before the blip by just trying to hit
the rewind button but the thing is there
is no rewind button once a major global
disaster strikes there's no putting that
cat back in the bag friends listen to us
over here in 2021 we would know but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and i
know you're pretty sad that this
episode's ending i know you're probably
like wow i wish i could keep watching
that matthew patrick guy see what he's
up to get all buddy buddy with him well
wouldn't you know it you're in luck
today's sponsor rocket mortgage
interviewed me and my partner steph over
on the rocket learn youtube channel all
about how we run these channels make
this content and manage to have life if
you squint at it really hard when we're
not talking about the issues of
nationalization border control and
global crises of the marvel universe
we're uh well we're probably researching
another episode but we do it all from
our house and have been for years on
this episode of their series big change
we show and talk about the place we
actually live which is not the sort of
thing that we typically do we're not big
youtube house tour kind of people but in
this behind the scenes sneak peek we
actually talk about how we make our
lives work and what it was like being
stuck in the same house as your business
partner during 2020. we literally run
our business around the world from our
basement and do it all in the comfort of
stretchy sweatpants that camouflage how
bad our pandemic diet really was if
you're interested in how you can run
your own youtube business or work from
home better or organize your space to
make it happen give it a watch so click
the link that's down in the description
or that's on the screen right now or is
in the upper right hand corner of your
tv and show us and them some love thank
you all so much for watching i'll see
you in the next video and cuts